amo cosa fai a capodanno
[Musica]
vuoi sapere cosa farò capodanno lavorerò
come tutti i giorni la verità mentre la
gente si divertirà scherzerà su
bianchera e festeggerà io saro li a
portare i piatti a sparecchiare portare
che ti sporchi a portare le bottiglie e
a farmi urlare dalla gente in faccia si
prospetta una bella serata no cosa poi a
capodanno dove vai a capodanno ma dove
devo andare
un giorno come un altro spaccato
riguardo una serie tv amo altri bene le
orecchie perché ho appena deciso cosa
faremo capodanno
allora andiamo alla festa di giacomo per
la mezzanotte poi andiamo al vanilla e
poi andiamo al mi vida dove fanno
reggaeton fino alle 9 del mattino e
palermo il mattino da mohammad per non
ti preoccupare per l'alcol perché ha già
preparato tutto o due motivi di portale
ma e una di coca o meglio capodanno 1
festeggia in famiglia da sempre cenno e
il cinepanettone
com'è che dice detto natale con i tuoi
capodanno pure amo l'ho trovato è lo
chalet di montagna perfetto per il
nostro capodanno sulla neve è pazzesco a
dieci stanze i rubinetti d'oro e gli
interni in legno una vera pacchia nata e
si le natale a cortina è la cosa più
delle che cosa pochissimo perché se
siamo in 15 e luca conferma verrebbe
esattamente 43 euro e 90 testa ci ha mai
regalato a noi siamo a luglio
non puoi pensarci un po più avanti al
capodanno cioè che non hanno mai adesso
che si deve prenotare il capodanno
e proprio a luglio che ci sono le grandi
occasioni non ne voglio sentire e inter
stasera lo dobbiamo bloccare l'uomo mi
dispiace ma non posso venire a ballare
con te capodanno fire mai dato la mia
parola roberto quest'anno festeggeremo
con i suoi ma non pensi una cosa noiosa
è anzi cioè divertentissimo loro dopo il
cenone si mettono tutti davanti alla
televisione e guardano di the best delle
cene di famiglia dell'anno appena
trascorso non è fantastico e poi
praticamente danno un oscar al miglior
familiare dell'anno supera originali amo
esco non esco
questo è il problema se non esco sto a
casa a guardare una serie come tutte le
sere della mia vita
e se esco beh potrei divertirmi magari
conoscere un ragazzo magari innamorarmi
magari sposarmi
vogliamo basso capiamo prima cosa fare
allora testa croce
esco ma
cosa vi metto buonanno tanti auguri a te
famiglia felice anno nuovo felice anno
nuovo de che ma cosa ma sarà un altro
anno di stop c'è da festeggiare ma cosa
avete tutti da festeggiare ma fatevi una
vita allora con calma vestito proiettato
vestito pitonato ho vestito total black
ragioniamoci su paiettato forse un po
scontato capodanno pitonato forse un po
pacchia nello total black
mi vesto sempre di nero escluda o non
esco proprio allora il vestito paiettato
cielo la cravatta per e dolce l'oeil
papillon per luca cielo e io mi metterò
questo fantastico cercato scritto
opinioni e andrò ma io dico ma che senso
ha spendere tutti quei soldi per una
cena di capodanno quando tutto il resto
dell'anno la paghi un terzo è proprio da
stupidi no antille miami polinesia
madagascar
new york tutti in giro per il mondo e io
a casa aspetta però potrei pubblicare
una foto vecchio e taggarmi a bora bora
cesco lo faccio subito a molini sa che
stasera resto a casa non ho tanta voglia
di uscire no scusa non ho capito già
capodanno due resterà casa ma si
impazzita
non ci siamo assolutamente riso tu ti
prepari e io alle 8 in punto ti passa
prendere e guai a te se mi fai
analizzato e muoviti
questo sì che è un capodanno divano
coperta e gigi d'alessio su canale 5
d'accordo va bene il 2018 non è stato
l'anno migliore della tua vita
ma come direbbe il grande antonello
quando pensi che sia finita è proprio
allora che incomincia la salita e io
quest'anno spaccherò tutto
il 2019 è il mio anno me lo sento sono
speranzoso amore
mi raccomando arriva puntuale che a
mezzanotte voglio un bel bacio
portafortuna
[Musica]
sì nei sogni forse a capodanno l'unico
uomo che ci sarà nei paraggi e il
fidanzato di erika e non mi sembra poco
il caso di baciarlo bene un altro anno
da single
forse non hai capito mancano due ore a
capodanno e noi non sappiamo ancora cosa
fare ma ci vogliamo dare una mossa
volevo rimanere a casa io a casa non ci
sto adesso andiamo in discoteca ci
saranno delle feste no tutti tesi
divertono tutte fidanzate non curate
loro sola festeggiare con chi o cosa non
ho alcun gatto prossimo anno sarà aperta
mai la gioia papa e avanzato un po di
panettone la fame o duro e dei
cioccolatini azzurro e degli amanti più
di allora questo si che è un capodanno
io la tv e il cibo
[Musica]